welcome to this video timo for Nekyia
this is a guy played twice and I didn't
score that well when win and one loss
and the loss was rather and bad I
remember he played exactly the same
thing in that game that I lost I'm key
probably all the way back ship where I
exactly seven I guess yeah I wonder be
six maybe seems ok trying to finish at
all that bishop it cannot be really bad
it's just i'm not sure i'm not very well
versed in the e6 alliance there but i
want to play them a little bit to get a
better feel for what's going on Joe what
has a good development here
not sure if this 197 is better maybe
ninety seven is better well it's really
quick quickly developed and now I can
take with the scene i'd rather it's
certainly not ideal and maybe 94
actually yes ma'am only now I'm really
seeing that this is a not too bad idea
night x is successor awkward possibility
but Quincy 896 Quincy 6 is playable so
this is not that that much of a problem
and 96 Quincy 6 as possible I his he has
the better position though clearly night
f5 is also move guy can take that sorry
I can take that takes Queen e7 Quincy
1496 Quincy 6 really does not forget who
I think
my next move is something like 95 or
Bishop t5 Toronto block that dangerous
b-36 diagonal
okay yeah 95 let's not spend too much
time Bishop f6 maybe to activate or rook
e8 who create Bishop athlete is also not
a bad idea it's God might be five though
hmm what hmm so at the end he claims
that this pin is too bad hard I don't as
possible maybe maybe he just I'm just
get killed agri getting killed by the
pin probably I am
rook da dro p5 is the point ah sick ah I
will seek is this
didn't you can see that beforehand or
what okay Bishop f6 says it says
something that I can try at least not
really I had just a loss Bishop t5 is
winning why is that something with the
back rank actually wait wait wait wait
wait wait
isn't that clear it isn't that clear
actually assured by bishop t5 as
possible bishop d 5 o-125 i will show
you five no answer ok
check yeah Bishop t5 Bishop g5 rock 25
simply one meet so here it has to take a
look 25 now yeah that's also nuts I can
they couldn't even do that because of
rupee one so look at the age now I guess
otherwise I cannot keep it still a bit
awkward with the pin so king of eight
still see for I have no square really
okay
it also put past Knight b6 after
unpinning
Knight b6 next Bishop d6 Bishop e7 is
okay game his pawns I somewhat looked
check ya might resign it was a really
weird game I am no probably not take the
six wasn't working but I didn't didn't
really think about it and he has a
decent position he definitely Knightly
five or so white is better right is
somewhat better yeah this is Chani
seemed to work but I was just shocked
how quickly plated yeah like after six
seconds can I have thought it was
working but it really isn't it really
isn't I haven't the sugar 6 and his weak
back like sorry it's costing him check
this this gym that's even worse it's
universe check and took this yeah a drug
chicks chat have this one and my whole
look up maybe after this this is the
best try no sorry the other one the
other one Bishop t5 Jack need check and
maybe this one he has two pawns for the
exchange create though now black is
better here but he can fight can put up
some fight I will win be too probably
he goes back up to turn or c4 you
shouldn't be too yeah black has very
decent winning chances here but it's
it's still a fight in the game it was
really just just a piece down okay well
thanks for watching